well the Prime Minister has promised to
return to Brussels with some new ideas
to try and solve the Irish backstopping
issue and writing in The Sunday
Telegraph to reason they once again
assures readers that the UK will leave
the EU on time but with only 8 weeks to
go there is quite a lot to do so
yesterday i sat down with the
international trade secretary Liam Fox
and I started by asking him what the
government's next steps are well we'll
continue to talk to our European
partners to see if we can get an
agreement and get an agreement as
possible time is moving on and there's
also increasing worry about the the
European economy and the state of the
global economy we've seen a big slowdown
in China that's had a knock-on effect
we've seen Italy now go into recession
we've seen the German economy slow down
the French economy slowed down really we
do need to avoid any disruption to that
European trading system you say that
you're gonna try and talk more to the EU
at the same time
Teresa nay is saying that she wants to
get some changes to that withdrawal
agreement but if you look at what EU
politicians and leaders are saying it
simply doesn't chime with that at all
Donald Tusk ur says the withdrawal
agreement not open for a renegotiation
the Irish government says the same
McCowen says the deal is not Murray
negotiable Janka says it's the best and
only possible deal is the government
diluted well are they really saying that
they would rather not negotiate and end
up in a new deal position I think that's
not a responsible approach to take it
would have an impact on the European
economy on jobs and prosperity and for
those leaders the British economy and
for the and for the British economy
absolutely and so it's in all our
interest to get to that agreement for
the EU to say we're not going to even
discuss it
seems to me quite they're responsible so
from the conversations that you're
having do you think some EU countries
are more open than others to negotiate I
think this as there always has been a
difference between the Member States and
the European Commission I think the
European Commission has a priority for
the political ideology of Europe about
ever closer Union and the Four Freedoms
member states who have governments who
need to be reelected have to worry about
real jobs real prosperity and real trip
let's talk about the back stop because I
mean that was Parliament's message
wasn't it that they'd accept the deal if
the backstop was effectively gotten rid
of but that's just not gonna happen is
it I mean I was speaking to the Irish
Europe Minister last week and she was
absolutely clear that this is not
something that Ireland can possibly
negotiate on well if they won't
negotiate on it then they are likely to
end up with no deal and the European
Union said that's the best route to get
a hard border so for the Irish I think
it's even more important than most that
they are willing to talk to us about
what the alternative ways are of
achieving no hard border because that's
the stated position of both the Irish
government the British government and
indeed the European Union one of the
things that may be a price for changes
to the backstop is the customs union
it's something that apparently
jean-claude Juncker has floated it's
certainly something that Labour are
pushing for if the customs union
something that you could stomach to get
a deal over the line no would you resign
well I think it would not fulfill the
promise we made to leave the European
Union we would not be taking back
control of our trade policy you cannot
have an independent trade policy if
you're in a customs union turkey finds
itself in that position at the moment it
can't even talk to the United Kingdom
but what might happen afterwards because
it's locked in a partial customs union
with the EU
so would you resign I thought the word
become well and I do think so I don't I
don't things about us I mean that makes
it about the politicians not about the
policy and I think we should concentrate
on the policy and I think that would be
a bad policy for the United Kingdom and
the other thing I'm very keen to Oishi
about is an extension to article 50 and
because this is something that has
increasingly been talked about because
frankly there's still so much stuff to
get done if there's gonna be any chance
of leaving the EU on the day that the
government wants to happen now
when we spoke in June you said this
about an extension of article 50 I
wouldn't find that politically
acceptable and I couldn't support it is
that your position still well that was
in the context of as not having reached
an agreement and simply extending the
time I don't think that solves anything
if we actually have an agreement and it
takes a little more time to get the
legislation through to make that as
smooth as possible I think that is a
very different argument it sounds a bit
like you're dancing on the head of a pin
that no I think there's a big difference
between if we have an agreement and we
need some time to get the legalities
done that's that's one thing I think to
extend simply because we hadn't reached
an agreement would not provide any
impetus for that agreement to be reached
and in any case there's no guarantee
that you would want to do that we're not
ready for no deal are we frankly well we
would be able to deal with that scenario
but it wouldn't be in our interest to go
there it seems to me we've got to guard
against two things one is irrational
pessimism that says you know everything
will be a catastrophe and irrational
optimism which says everything will be
absolutely ok the truth lies between the
two if we left the European Union with
no dealer would be disruption to our
trade the disruption to European trade
as well it wouldn't be in our best
interest to do that of course it's
survivable but we don't want to be
putting our economy into a position of
unnecessary turmoil my question though
is if you say it's just survivable but
it could have been better than this
couldn't it if the government had
started preparing for No Deal and an
earlier date this is where a lot of the
issues form isn't it why weren't you
preparing for no deal from day one well
you're sitting here in the Department
for international trade and our very
existence has been about preparing for
post brexit and we've always had the
view that we might get no deal so let's
try to prepare for that and and across
the whole of the private sector looking
to see whether they can make their was
appropriate mitigations well let's talk
about the preparation for the department
because if we do leave the EU then we're
going to be losing access to 40 trade
deals that's 12 percent of our trade how
many of those have been rolled over well
first of all we would not lose access to
that tree
because a great deal of that trade is
done and would continue to be done I on
world trade terms those agreements are
worth about it's all about 11.1% let's
not quibble about 0.9% a number of those
are already signed you know we've signed
the Australia and the New Zealand mutual
recognition agreement slightly chilly we
sent we've signed the Chile agreement
we're just about to sign the Swiss
agreement we've signed Faroe Islands
which is important for fishing this week
and we'll want to bring them through as
we go on we're talking to a number of
those countries about how we finalize
them and they will come some very late
in the day as we get towards the 29th of
our still quite a small number isn't it
it's not really because if you look at
those agreements five of those
agreements represent eight out of that
eleven percent we hear a lot about the
WTO you're just talking there about the
WTO and how worried are you about the
fact that this is an organization that
is going through a rocky period to say
the least I mean look at the way that
the u.s. is blocking or trying to block
charges to the WTO I mean is this really
the right time to be relying on this
organization yes and it's in fact time
to help strengthen the WTO and update
the WTO there are a whole range of
issues you mentioned just a couple of
them but there are others the fact that
we have not liberalized services the way
we've liberalized goods the fact that
even the differentiation between what is
a good and what's the services blurred
and yet the mechanics around governance
are not clear I said to my Chinese
counterpart some time ago I said if I
had asked you the question in 1995 if I
sell you a digital code over the
internet to make something on your 3d
printer have I sold you a good or a
service you even have understood that
question in 1995 and yet we're using the
same rules to govern the global economy
when that global economy itself is
fundamentally different so we do need to
update the WTO and as we take up our
independent seat after we leave the EU
that will be one of our great priorities
do you worry though the way that some
supporters of brexit talk about the WTO
like this is the fix-all solution to any
issues we might have if we
leave the EU without a deal well most of
our trade most of world trade operates
under WTO terms are the trade bills -
something like that is my point indeed
the if WTO was was so good people
wouldn't be looking to have trade
agreements or customs unions which are
ways in which you can further improve on
those WTO rules and it's always seemed
to me a bit strange that people would
say well we don't need to worry about
having a future trade deal with Europe
we can operate on WTO terms while at the
same time saying we should have a free
trade agreement with United States to
get away from WTO rules so we have to be
consistent do you think and that Therese
may was right or wrong to decide not to
call on the services of a coffered
falconer who is the top trade negotiator
at your department someone that many
people very respectful of when it comes
to a post brexit can trade future for
the UK well let me tell you he's not
exactly underemployed at the moment he's
extremely busy here in this department
as the chief negotiator prepared answer
did you think he's he's busy enough I
it's not I don't think it's we should be
delving into which bits of the civil
service are used for which it's the
government policy that matters but do
you think he would do a good job at
tourism they did decide to to use him oh
I think he does a great job but what do
I do if he's doing something else what
do you make about the way that tourism
A's handled the negotiations
well the Prime Minister's had a very
difficult and because she's not only
been negotiating with the European Union
at times she's been negotiating with her
own party this is a leaf country with a
remain Parliament and it's a parliament
with mana remain minutes with no
majority for the Primus has been very
clear and I think has been very
insistent on carrying out the will of
the British people in the referendum I
wish more people in our Parliament would
do what they were elected to do which
was to fulfill the promise they made to
honor that referendum do you think that
people who don't may be punished in the
ballot box the next election then well
80% of MPs in this Parliament were
elected on a manifesto either liberal
conservative promising to honour the
result of the referendum those who get
elected on that promise and then don't
follow it through once they get to
Parliament I think we'll have a
difficult time with the voters the next
time and if that happens then they
deserve it